kiama wanted to make a classical gothic
romance he just wanted to reclaim the
horror genre to infuse it with the
classical tone to make it romantic again
and create a visual world that you could
disappear into ghosts are real that much
I know there is a beautiful genre called
Gothic romance that it combines an
almost fairy tale dark atmosphere
ghostly supernatural but very classy
with a very heightened melodrama and
that used to be done in Hollywood in
with high budgets with great production
with a great I to detail and you've got
lost after the fifties and sixties he
started waning down and nobody was doing
it anymore I wanted to make a an almost
old-fashioned grand style Hollywood
production
I don't think she's the right choice you
have to trust me the house is almost
like a character in the film and he
built it from scratch you don't really
see things like this in movies anymore
to throw back to another era and
American filmmaking where they used to
build these sets they built a
three-story mansion in this soundstage
in Toronto it was all to scale and all
the furniture and artwork and detail was
just so beautiful it really helped
inform haces actors to sort of
understand the world and the tone and
what we were apart of this was
undoubtedly the most amazing beautiful
set I've ever really seen imax is like I
give you a magnifying glass you're gonna
catch a lot more than a regular audience
because I much has this immersive
quality well the great thing about imax
is you really feel like you're part of
the experience it's not really watching
a film you're experiencing in the film
where movie like crimson peak that has
really cultivated all the visuals you
can see all the little details I truly
think if you watch crimson peak in imax
you will disappear into this world you
will be submerged and immersed into a
kind of heightened realm that's set in
the past and it'll be like inhabiting
crimson peak itself
you